accueil en revanche beaucoup plus mitigé
pour le très controversé antichrist du
danois lars von triers et c'est
charlotte gainsbourg qui se risque à
jouer dans ce film très violent qui a
choqué beaucoup de ceux qui l'ont vu sur
la croisette sabine gorny antoine
placier une odeur de souffre dans cannes
aujourd'hui le diable le malin satan et
tous les maléfices s'était invitée
partout sur la croisette jusqu'à
s'immiscer dans nos têtes tout ses
démons intérieurs à lui le danois lars
von trier exercice de choc ne pas se
fier à son air angélique les névroses de
l'ars au cinéma ça donne ça dans une
forêt hostile
un couple endeuillé par la mort de son
enfant sous course du fantastique du
sexe du gore et une surenchère de
violence
un peu secoué ségo dans le rôle de la
mère folle de douleur puis folle tout
court
la douce et pudique charlotte gainsbourg
qui se met à nu au vrai sens du terme
par amour et respect du cinéaste elle a
tout accepté violence extrême nudité
déjà d'avoir à exprimer
un état de crise comme sa permanence et
s&p salle d'impudeur et
donc on allait déjà très loin sans sens
le fait de se déshabiller d'aucune
importance en fait un thriller thérapie
imaginé par le cinéaste pour se guérir
d'une dépression on y retrouve ses
fantasmes ses obsessions et une vision
noire des femmes
incarnation du mal absolu il ya eu
tellement de films où le diable et
masculin mais moi je pense que les
femmes doivent aussi avoir le mauvais
rôle au cinéma
ce n'est que justice avec cette plongée
érotique horrifique dans l'enfer de
l'âme humaine
le festival a connu son premier petit
scandale diablement efficace pour la
promo d'un film qu'on pourra aimer ou
détester le 3ans prochain